in the last video we figured out the
volume between this surface which was XY
squared and the XY plane when X was went
from 0 to 2 and Y went from 0 to 1 and
with the way we did it is we integrated
with respect to X first we said let us
hold Y pick a Y and let's just figure
out the area under the curve and so we
integrated with respect to X first and
then we integrated with respect to Y but
we could have done it the other way
around so let's let's do that and just
make sure we got the right the right
answer so let me erase a lot of this so
remember our answer was 2/3 when we
integrated with respect to X first and
then with respect to Y but I will show
you that we can integrate the other way
around
that's good when you can get the same
answer in two different ways so let me
redraw redraw that graph because I want
to give you the intuition again so
that's my x axis y axis z axis X Y Z and
let me make then this is my XY plane
down here alright Y goes from 0 to 1 X
goes from 0 to 2 alright this is going
to be this x equals 1 this is x equals 2
this is y equals 1 and then the graph I
will do my best to draw it look
something let me do it anymore and get
some contrast going here so the graph
looks something like this let me see if
I can draw it this side it looks
something like that
and then it comes down comes down like
that straight and then the volume we
care about is actually this volume
underneath the graph this is the top of
the surface on that side and we care
about this volume underneath the surface
and then when we draw the bottom of the
surface let me do it in a darker color
like something like this this is the
bottom underneath underneath the surface
I could even shade it a little bit just
to show you that it's like the
underneath underneath the surface
hopefully that's a decent rendering of
it
alright let's look back at what we had
before right it's like a page that I
just flipped up at this point we care
about this volume kind of the colored
area under there so let's figure out how
to do last time we integrate with
respect to X for us let's integrate with
respect to Y first so let's hold X
constant so if we hold X constant what
we can do is for a given X let's pick an
X and let's say what is so if we if we
pick a given X I don't let's pick the X
I know here then what we can do if we're
given X you can view that function of x
and y right if X is a constant let's see
if you know if X is 1 then Z is just
equal to Y squared right and that's easy
to figure out the area under as we can
see that X isn't a concept we can treat
it as a constant so for example for any
given X we would have a curve like this
right and what we could do is we could
try to figure out the area of this curve
first so how do we do that
well we just said we could kind of view
this function up here as Z is equal to
XY squared because that's exactly what
it is but we're holding X constant we're
treating it like a constant and to
figure out that area we could take a dy
a change in Y a dy multiply it by the
height which is XY squared right so we
take XY squared XY squared multiply it
by dy and if we want this entire area we
integrate it from Y is equal to 0 to Y
is equal to 1 Y is equal to 0 from 0 to
1 fair enough now once we have that air
if we want the volume underneath this
entire surface what we could do is we
can multiply this area times DX and get
some depth to going pick a nice color
that's green
so let's say our that's our DX so if we
multiply that times DX we would get some
depth let me do a darker color get some
contrast sometimes I feel like that guy
who paints on PBS DX so now we have the
volume of this you can kind of view the
area of the curve times the DX so we
have some depth here so it's x DX if we
want to figure out the entire volume
under this surface between the surface
and the xy-plane given this constraint
to our domain we just integrate from X
is equal to 0 to 2 X is equal to Z from
0 to 2 alright so once we so let's think
about it this area this area in green
here that we started with that should be
a function of X right we held X constant
but depending on which X you pick this
area is going to change right so when we
evaluate this magenta inner integral
with respect to Y we should get a
function of X and then well your value
the whole thing will get our volume so
let's do it
let's evaluate this inner integral hold
X constant what's the antiderivative of
Y squared is y to the third over 3 right
so it's Y third over 3 the X is a
constant right and we're going to
evaluate that at 1 and a 0 and the outer
integral is still with respect to X DX
this is equal to let's see when you
evaluate Y is equal to 1 you get 1 to
the 3rd that's 1 so it's x over 3 minus
when y is 0 then that's whole thing just
becomes 0 right so this this this purple
expression is just x over 3 x over 3 and
then we still have the outside integral
from 0 to 2 DX so given what X we have
the area of this green surface that
babbles out where we started given any
given X that area now I wanted something
with some contrast this area is x over 3
depending on which X you pick if X is 1
this area right here is 1/3 right but
now we're going to integrate across the
the entire surface and get our volume
and like I said when you integrate it
it's a function of X so let's do that
and this is just plain old vanilla
standard integral so what's the
antiderivative of X it's x squared over
2 we have a 1/3 there so it equals x
squared over 2 times 3 so x squared over
6 we're going to evaluate it at 2 and at
0 2 squared over 6 is 4 6 minus 0 over 6
which is equal to 0 equals 4 6 what is 4
6 well that's just the same thing as 2/3
so the volume under the surface is 2/3
and if you watch the previous video you
will appreciate the fact that when we
when we changed when we integrated the
other way around when we did it with
respect to X first and then Y we got the
exact same answer so that the universe
is in proper working order and I've
surprisingly actually finished this
video with extra time so for fun we can
just spin this graph and just appreciate
the fact that we have figured out the
volume between this surface XY squared
and the xy-plane
pretty neat anyway I'll see you in the
next video